[Music]
[Applause]
Bill Everett he hosted SportsCenter for
23 years and uh Last Friday Night final
broadcast for the mothership and uh now
leaving ESPN 23 years hey
congratulations on lasting that long
hey Dan if if I know I you know I was at
ESPN 20 plus years if I'd known it who
was going to take leaving to get on your
show I would have left a long time
but
why did you leave
I just uh uh it was time to go you know
um I didn't want ESPN to be my last
chapter uh and once again like you
showed all of us that you could
leave ESPN and still not only survive
but Thrive doing something else but it
is tough jumping off that Cliff yeah
because those four letters are so
powerful and you could hide behind them
and uh you know get ESPN muscles there
but also I'm wondering about the the
sports center teams as as we move down
the road with whatever SportsCenter is
or what it's going to be you and Stan
veret were doing this together for a
long long time and probably the last of
the known anchor teams there it is it
being discouraged or or you know that
even Embrace that they want to have
sports center teams anymore
oh those are just those are decisions
that are made with guys who had offices
in uh in Bristol not guys who had cubes
in Los Angeles so uh Stan and I you know
listen Stan and I looked up to you and
Keith and you know we tried to emulate
you in in the ways that we could and uh
and have a camaraderie and bring the
entertainment and uh and do the
highlights the way that uh that we grew
up watching them and and hopefully we
succeeded in that how important was it
when you first started to have a
catchphrase for a highlight
oh it's just my bartender just came to
me and I you know I I never nobody said
hey you gotta have a catchphrase what
people said was you got to be in a
commercial I remember I went home to
Hawaii and I I'm like hey I'm gonna be
on Sports Center we're gonna be on
SportsCenter and all anyone wanted to
know was when are you going to do a
commercial that's all anybody wanted so
but the catchphrases are fun they're
part of the they're part of the E and
the entertainment and the ESPN yeah I I
and I remember when we were trying to
get athletes to come to ESPN to Bristol
to do those commercials and man was it
tough because they all wanted to know
were they going to get paid and then
when you said we'll make a charitable
donation in your name
and then nobody wanted to come so I said
to Jason Kidd in Grant Hill I said would
you do me a favor
would you would you come to ESPN and
then they were like for a day like how
long and then I said it would be for a
day and then all of a sudden the
reaction when other athletes saw those
guys do those commercials then the
floodgates open everybody wanted to have
their own commercial is there one that
you were involved in that stands out the
most
oh yeah it was the Roger Federer
commercial it's the first one I did I
was the only person in it uh I'm you
know Roger if they ranked anchors where
would I be you know one through ten I'm
not sure you'd be in the top 10 meal and
I was able to give him stink eye and say
I'd be in the top 10 and what's really
funny about that was Roger Roger Federer
wrote me after that and he said hey I've
did some research you're definitely in
the top ten would you like to be my
guest at the US Open and I'm like yeah
oh that's what I wrote it back yeah
oh
following up yeah
yeah I ever heard from him again I'm
watching the US Open and they show Roger
oh there's Roger betters oh Tiger Woods
is there I'm like Raj I've never heard
from him since
what was the your favorite thing on
social media the reaction when you were
leaving ESPN did anything stand out
well I don't I'm not on social media but
people forward some stuff to me and uh
the one that stood out the most to me
and I I said it on is my uh on the on
the way out of La was somebody wrote and
said I've watched ESPN religiously for
20 years and I don't even know who this
guy is you're talking about
I think I think that remind gave me a
little perspective uh are you setting up
shop in Hawaii for for good
uh well there's Hawaii there's Oregon
and there's California so I'm I'm you
know the the grass under my feet is
growing it's time to move on it's time
to get going and where that where that
lands I don't know I've been working for
the Trailblazers the last couple of
years I've got opportunities in Hawaii I
love living in L.A uh so we'll see what
happens
well you're with the Blazers uh if you
ran the Blazers what would you do with
Dame Lillard Neil Levert oh David Dave
has earned a a level of respect from
Portland and you have to you have to
really be in Portland OR be of Portland
to understand Damian Lillard's uh grip
on Portland uh you know he's he's stayed
there he he could run for mayor right
now if not governor and win he's that
popular uh I'd have a hard time being
the guy who let Damian Lillard go
congratulations and uh just another
chapter coming up there and don't be
afraid
I appreciate it Dan I mean again you
you're a guy who uh you're the pros Pro
uh we've I've always watched you and
said you know Dan Patrick is the I want
to tell like I want to be like Dan
Patrick I want to be Dan Patrick I want
to be I want to be cool like Dan Patrick
and we know the cool is the rule man
thank you Neil and uh we appreciate your
time
appreciate you having me that's Neil
Everett hosted ESPN SportsCenter for 23
years